it sounds like Nintendo is testing the
eSports waters with their latest one off
show Nintendo has announced that a Mario
Kart themed TV show will air later this
week the one-off program called clash of
karts mario kart 8 will be broadcast on
Disney XD starting on December 5th clash
of parts will see eight of America's
best young gamers team up with YouTube
personalities in a mario kart 8
competition in front of a live audience
the show is an hour long and the
participants will play multiple rounds
of the popular racing game this isn't
Disney XD's first partnership with
Nintendo in October the network aired an
hour-long special from the Nintendo
World Championships competitive gaming
event that took place in June at e3
disney XD senior vice president mark boo
Hodge said in an interview with fortune
that this program was popular and
encouraged the network to move forward
with other eSports content Mario Kart 8
was chosen because of its wide appeal
and how it doesn't take itself too
seriously boo Hodge said eSports is
something that's blossoming but it's
still in early days how it will be
covered for the kids audience is still
something that remains to be seen with
5.8 7 million units sold as of September
30th mario kart 8 is the best-selling
Wii U game to date will you tune in on
December fit to check out clash of carts
and do you think kids will watch for
more video game related news stay tuned
to gamespot